Santa's been thrown right Oh Crowder and
and Tristan Thompson continued to jaw
both of them were hit with technicals
earlier now was it one or the other or
both
I wonder what transpired again on the
free-throw room I don't know the entire
Cavalier coaching staff is on the floor
I think they ejected both of them
the conversationalist at conversation
all right here's your rules Clinic
Thompson has been ejected because he has
been ejected and is still the free-throw
shooter the Grizzlies get to pick the
Cavaliers free-throw shooter John Henson
its lobbying for it to be him he was at
the score state will waiting to check in
anyway so he is also he's 48 percent
from the free-throw line well the thing
is Jae Crowder hasn't left them looks
like he went sat on the bench you know
he's he's not been teed up oh that's
good no JT JT you're indicated that
Thompson has been ejected but not
Crowder yep that is the reason why and
so Thompson has been dismissed from the
remainder of this evenings proceedings